welcome back to be rockstars this is the
big question quarantine Edition it's a
show that gives you too much information
about the terrifying implications of a
monster known as groups I'm Erik Bosse
talking talking trees with Phillip Elena
how you do buddy I'm okay
yeah what's going I'm starting to run
really low on liqueurs and like I'm just
getting like like college quality I made
a bitanga today I don't know what that
is so tequila and coke all out of
everything and there's some lime in
there I mean I'm still gonna get drunk
your standards have been raised now that
you're like a mixologist now like you
can't drink that that trash liquor that
the rest of us are okay with um trash
liquor is better than people think you
can hide anything oh yeah
you mix anything with coke mix it
anything with coke and everything they
expect all parties things do you have
you ever done cocaine no I've never seen
cocaine I've been around it you saw
cocaine at that show that we were both
that you saw the most cocaine anyone's
ever seen you see I you're right that is
true that is the one time I've seen
cocaine that should be that needs to be
a story that we tell Eric mail bag
what is Groot what the [ __ ] is Groot
what is he what are his secrets okay
you're right
this is a question that has been around
for a couple years and recently we did
our breakdown of guardians of the galaxy
part of our infinity saga rewatch and we
realized Groot is by far the weirdest
character in the MCU what he is exactly
and how he functions biologically tells
us a lot about him and the fact that he
has some enormous secrets nail his ass
okay so groot is defined as a flora
Colossus which is a tree-like organism
but he's not a tree he's not a plant
he's a animal and he turns to steel
that's that's a different Colossus
classes so thes and our booking when
they all get arrested on zan are in the
first movie the read out lists him as a
humanoid plant inhabitant of two Lunia
until Unni has also known as Planet X
which is the home of Groot and the flora
colossi his whole race is tribe is
people Khaleesi would bag plant still a
balloon so the flora colossi are ruled
over by what's called the arbor masters
this is like the recent guardians the
galaxy comics everything's kind of
tongue-in-cheek which is what's great
about them they teach their children
with photonic knowledge which is the
collected knowledge of all the arbor
masters of the generation after
generation is absorbed through
photosynthesis
it's a highly advanced education method
it's a super smart species that we're
dealing with they are not simple they're
smarter than all of us like Groot
himself isn't he like genius category
he's extremely smart he seems simple
because he just says I am Groot I am
Groot
well let's move on to his language the
reason he says I am Groot it's because
his physiology has stiffened their
larynxes and the the kind of wooden
fibrous state so that I am Groot it's
just what it sounds like when he says
anything it's like his ridet you
wouldn't call a frog gribbit just
because he says ribbit that's just wow
he vocalizes anything but every I am
Groot means something like a dog bark
they kind of roughly sound the same but
we can't hear the little intricacies
unless you teach your dog to talk with
buttons as you are the guardians of the
galaxy actually have a version of that
James Gunn established universal
language implants that all the
characters outside of Earth have so they
can understand each other and whatever
their native tongue is what I love is
that in his case I am Groot is we are
too stupid to understand him and his
genius level intellect in his subtleties
and his speech patterns but poor poor
Hodor he just got that brand donkey
ticket ahead
yikes yeah time travel destroyed his
brain forever yeah yeah like you put
these two in a room together and
everybody's ago they probably won't get
along and groots like are you kidding me
end up with a dum-dum
yeah what I love about this is when
James Gunn has written out the scripts
of the guardians of the galaxy movies he
writes all groots lines in English and
then he shows those English lines only
to Vin Diesel and then he translated
them all back to I am Groot so like
that's how he tells Vin Diesel how to
act because otherwise he would just say
like boom so every time we hear I am
Groot there is an English translation to
that and we get a sense of that if you
watch through the guardians of the
galaxy V movies you can see how each
time he says I am Groot usually rocket
will respond kind of like how the other
kids in South Park will respond to Kenny
and you can figure out by context what
it is he's relieved you don't want him
do oh he hates heads Oh on anyone not
just himself
[Music]
I love this recently James Gunn just
revealed that baby Groot in volume 2
dropped 50 f-bombs through hell out of
this I saw that yeah yeah so pretty much
every time you're hearing him talk he's
dropping a [ __ ] in there and you see a
tease of this in infinity war when we
catch up on teenage group yeah there's
there's a lot of swearing going on he's
very very profane now a heartfelt
language translation we didn't realize
this at the moment but groots final I am
Groot when he's dusting away in front of
rocket and what kinda he says no James
Gunn tweeted later that what group was
saying there was dad those were his
final words the rocket so we're talking
about an emotionally intelligent Lee
complex creature with all kinds of like
inner secrets and inner workings going
on behind that brain so while he seems
like the lovable simpleton of the Marvel
Universe he's actually one of the most
complex characters right I know I saw in
the comic where Jean Grey is actually
able to access his thoughts and actually
hear essentially some elaborate kind of
speech almost yeah which is one of the
most like fascinating moments cuz Jean
Grey is one of the most like complex
mutants of the Marvel Comics it has like
multiple identities and she can like
process everyone's psionic waves and
read everyone's thoughts cuz she's a
telepath and an empath so to have that
kind of connection with Groot and
they're both on the same level just
gives you a sense of what kind of
sophistication we're dealing with in
this green thing okay I have a question
yes I'm gonna ask a question and then
you can only respond with I am Erik or I
am boss which everyone and I'm gonna try
to see if I can read your mind and your
delivery okay
why did you keep it a secret that you
dated my ex-girlfriend immediately after
I finished dating her you didn't think
you didn't think you'd be into it
[Music]
but you saw heaven and Jerry Seinfeld
let's go
I am Bob hates me
we had to cut all the other ones because
I revealed too much
well I think you can learn a lot about
what groots futures gonna be by just
applying botany in real-world science
and biology to groots growth structure
which real-life biology and forestry
experts have examined and studied groots
behavior in groots different forms
throughout the films and made some very
interesting conclusions that i think we
all need to dig into Oh sir first let's
talk about how Groot regenerates so
Groot regenerates by just cutting off a
piece of Groot and replanting it so we
saw that between volume 1 and volume 2
he grew and in a pot and became baby
Groot botanist James Wong explained that
this process is called vegetative
propagation so plants retain their stem
cells throughout their lives baby Groot
according to him as a genetic clone of
Groot and volume 1 and James Long even
suggested that baby Groot might retain
the memories of group from volume 1 but
James Gunn clarified several times a
baby Groot an teenage group it's not the
original group they doesn't have the
same memories that original Groot it's
dead so I have a sample here this is my
oh my god Eric don't kill that plant
just for this episode I can't kill this
plant this plant is my succulent
Josephine and I love her and she's been
with me for four years she that's a
succulent that's huge it's yes she's
gotten enormous she used to have another
part to her that part died this leafy
part is still alive so if I were to cut
off a branch of hers I don't think I'd
be able to replant it but certain plates
you can yeah this plant needs very
little water root is interesting because
Groot does eat human food he eats pizza
in the comics
yeah it's candy and volume too but he
has like leaves that grow off of him he
eats his own leaves in the first film
so forestry experts have said that they
must have stoma which is on the
underside of the leaves that's how they
absorb carbon from the atmosphere to
photosynthesize with sunlight and create
sugars that feed the plant and allow it
to grow more fibrous material too so we
can grow larger sexy now a lot of
botanists who are a bit crazier on the
fringe of
the botany community has said that
always an IV yeah the future Poison
Ivy's in the making
they claim that plants have most senses
that animals have with the exception of
hearing though some say that plants can
hear like in a way oh yeah my mom talks
to her plants like crazy all the time oh
yeah all right and then they tell her
that I burn things well they're just
trying to save humanity but they grow
much healthier than like anyone elses
plants I've ever seen so I'm convinced
to actually do here yeah I mean I talked
to my plants I named my plants this is
Josephine she has a brother named Joseph
who's a different plant so they probably
aren't related but I adopt them because
they're so much Erik no relation they
might be [ __ ] behind the scenes
they're step-siblings so it's just a
little temperature like an clueless yeah
okay so plants respond to chemicals that
they say is similar to our process of
smelling it's the chemical process they
have photoreceptors they they grow
toward light which is kind of a form of
movement but not like the way group
walks around or dances they also have
what's called proprioception which is a
sense of location in space so like
plants know when they're upside down I
don't want to flip this don't do it and
they also will send off chemical signals
to communicate with other plants to warn
of infestations so they look out for
each other they we are also a botanist
named Simon Gilroy claims that plants
know when they're being touched
but knowing no Josephine show us on this
demo where he touched it there's also
this guy named Eric north who's a
forestry expert who studied groots
growth pattern
so he actually charted these out based
off of two different growth models and
there's two different growth rates that
Tree Experts use they use an exponential
function and that would assume that
Groot has reached his maximum height
which in the MCU is twelve four and
volume one but there's also a power
function that assumes trees could just
grow and grow and grow and that would
assume groots growth pattern he could
just keep growing forever and the only
reason he reached that height is because
he died at the end of volume one so he's
using the fact that in volume one then
diesel in an interview described his
character as a college freshman which
implies that
he had a whole lot more life after that
so I'm using that assumption the latter
model the power function would be more
accurate and if you apply that
mathematically group could grow to be 28
feet tall in a hundred years so just in
conclusion here Vin Diesel has teased
the fact that alpha Groot is what's
coming next and James Gunn was asked
about this he's like I don't know but
this was in the same kind of press
junket where Vin Diesel said that Groot
and maybe some other guardians
characters are gonna crossover in Thor 4
so my interpretation of that is we might
see like alpha Groot like a wrestler
Groot who like fights in the Sekar arena
you think all the groups we've seen
we've seen baby Groot we've seen teenage
group we've seen the original Groot is a
tree what else could we see what else
could alpha group mean other than a
giant group like an Iron Giant root who
is hundreds of feet tall with that same
level sophistication
I feel like based off of what we know
from botany and real-life science alpha
Groot means we're gonna see a giant
group in one of these MCU movies coming
- I feel like couldn't he make himself
giant with his group powers you know you
can kind of just like kind of a
Gretchen's yeah just kind of just you
know mr. fantastics
yeah but that would be like you know how
a jellyfish can just kind of stretch
itself out it's still the same amount of
mass it's just you know how do you know
that about jellyfish jellyfish are
immortal
they only die me if we kill them stop
believing in them so Philip do you feel
like you understand what Groot is and
maybe what his secrets are it sounds
like he's a complex genius who holds the
secrets to the universe and can get
really big genius billionaire playboy
philanthropist exec that's awesome I
love it I love I now know what good is
maybe I should have asked why is group
do we just do a Groot down and I didn't
see with that one idiot I am
oh no you're not dumb you know why
you're not dumb why am I not done
because you are the one that introduced
me to express VPN ah yes expressvpn
I think you do expressly Piedra
sponsoring this episode experts to be P
N is like an IP blocker it allows you to
navigate to the internet without people
like tracking your data or preventing
you from seeing certain things based on
what country you live in so you might
know that expressvpn protects your
privacy and security online it can also
help you unlock movies and shows that
are only available in certain countries
yes this is awesome we were talking
about this on a recent episode of rogue
theory that you can watch a lot of Star
Trek stuff that you can't watch
otherwise I'm without paying extra for
it on Netflix if you just set yourself
it in Canada I think it is for that one
you can watch the card
Star Trek discovery you can also watch
like Rick and Morty to the new episodes
on freaking Netflix if you stay here in
France
yeah Doctor Who is on Netflix in the UK
so if you can't watch either of those or
lots of other shows if you are just like
saying you're on the United States
Netflix but using expressvpn you can
change your location refresh Netflix or
Hulu or whatever streaming service
you're using and then you can access
this stuff regardless of where you live
again Eric said it but it hides your IP
address so you can also look at whatever
the hell you want on any web site go
anywhere and you can change where you're
located and they don't know who you are
they're gonna think it's somebody in the
Caribbean that's looking at that weird
weird jellyfish stuff yeah you can
choose from almost a hundred different
countries there are hundreds of VPNs out
there but we use Express VPN because it
is ridiculously fast there's never any
buffering or lag you can stream HD with
zero problems and if we haven't
mentioned it doesn't it's not just like
a computer thing it works on your smart
phone you can use on your smart TV you
can use on your consoles and stuff it
works on all of it yeah if you visit our
special link right now at expressvpn
comm slash big q b.i.g
q you can get an extra three months of
expressvpn for free you can support the
show watch whatever you want protect
yourself with vixx RSVP at expressvpn
comm slash big q okay let's move on to
some bite-sized questions that Philips
gonna answer are you ready Philip yeah
I'm excited
these are fun okay our friend composer
95 on discord asked what if Thanos
couldn't physically snap his fingers
some people can't snap is is the snap
part necessary also uh Louis Lemoine in
the comments of a previous video access
as well yes same thing alright and I've
been asking this question for too long
songs I'm like do we really need to do
this this is oddly specific especially
when you're in a metal glove would [ __ ]
in May
that's out
and also like it's just like these
ancient stones and stuff but they had
the foresight to be like let's make it a
snap thing and they're like some of us
don't have fingers inside well that's
why you can't ever snap like it just is
such a weird thing that it's a snap I
went down a bunch of rabbit holes trying
to figure this out and I looked into
like the origin of snapping and the snap
snap your fingers snap your fingers turn
on like that was my idea
I gotta shake out a patent that's the
first time anybody ever used it no it
was in 1607 or so but I mean honestly
it's not that interesting what you once
you try to find it
so let's just talk about the snap itself
in the movie the reason that they have
it is I would say the biggest reason is
just a direct reference to the Infinity
Gauntlet comics and in the comics it
makes a lot of sense right you're going
through this epic storyline most epic
storyline ever and you're trying to show
how crazy things are about to get and
going from one panel to the next it's
not really clear why anything is any
different on some cosmic or universal
scale so they use something visible like
a one framed thing like a snap where
they can make a sound out of it and then
in the comic you understand the before
is gone and the after starts right on
this panel I mean and like yeah they
technically could have shown like a
bunch of rainbow colors shooting out or
something but we've actually seen that
to mean other stuff like when Thanos
uses all of the stones at once on an
incoming Thor like it might have just
been confusing versus just let's make it
about the snap thing sure but in the
movie so not only is it a reference to
the comics but I'm also pretty sure that
they're kind of just using this
screenwriting technique I call it a
ticking cloth but essentially just means
that something that you're getting
closer to and closer to and it's very
definitive so you often see it on a bomb
that's why I call it ticking clock
because you can see the numbers are
almost there and they even really
underline this in the movie and when dr.
strange and others they're weirdly
obsessed with it
don't let him close his fist and it's
just like this like random rule that
they just assign to it like it'd be
closes its fist all is lost
yeah but that's kind of brilliant right
like it's a simple gesture that everyone
around the world gets it's just like a
snap of a finger it's a it's like so
simple in binary like a snap is such a
quick on and off yeah right it's like a
switch and which is what it kind of
looks like in the comics too it's just
kind of an on-off switch almost
so I think that they were you they
decided to go and keep that for the
movies because it's so definitive we
know all is lost the moment we see that
and it actually is a satisfying enough
payoff to just know yes they failed the
moment he does that but it doesn't make
any sense obviously
the Avengers have never like dealt with
the gauntlet before they're not like
there's only one way to the gauntlet
where it's like it kind of is a little
random so if I was coming up with an
in-universe solution for why this would
be we could say maybe Doctor Strange
when he looked at every different
possibility or something he saw that no
matter what happens anytime Thanos
creates the the change that he's looking
for he does it by snapping his fingers
because Thanos we do know is a really
big fan of the phrase snap of one's
fingers he had said multiple times to
Gamora that he could white people out at
the snap of his fingers he's we've seen
him used that phrase in the films so
it's like he himself is like you know
what there's only one way I'm gonna do
this thing and it's in this cheeky
little sassy way that I've been building
up to I've been saying it for years I've
been saying it so this is the only way
I'm gonna do it that's the only way
totally makes sense in the universe why
Doctor Strange knows if he goes too
close his hand he's gonna do it cuz
technically the way the stones work he
could have done it anyway he could have
done it literally with just a thought
yeah I also like he could have done it
with any other motion right he could
have done peace signs or never could
have done it yeah big cue to hit
everybody the only one I think would be
better than Snap is have you done double
finger guns oh you're out
[Music]
that's one of our emojis than our
discord right it's doing those yeah it
doesn't need to be a snap if he had no
fingers he could still do it some other
way it's just like as weirdly he would
only do it that way that's interesting
it kind of implies that like a snap
gesture was specific to Thanos his past
like maybe as a kid like he was abused
by just being like take him outside and
beat him you know and snap he's like I'm
gonna use that against the world
universe maybe it was just like his like
big old stupid thumbs like he couldn't
snap to music or poetry and he was just
like one day I'll make a gauntlet thank
you
maybe he's like partially using the
reality sum to be able to snap because
he can't do it normally and finally
what's the every audience yes now I can
now again okay another bite-sized
question this is from Eddie de Leon from
the comments of our videos if ant-man
was to shrink kneel near would it still
be hard to lift I love this question so
much I love any all this like stuff we
think about an ant-man and shoving them
up and stuff just all these like weird
things computer Ludum phantoms please oh
I'm okay you should be able to do so
much more so the first thing I assess in
answering this was can ant-man shrink me
linear and luckily I'm an adult man who
watches cartoons for children remember
there's an episode of Avengers Assemble
and it's it's a it's not a good episode
obviously but there's this moment where
like such a Pym particles get loose
there's like robots and stuff and it
Thor throws his hammer and as it's
flying through the air interacts with
kind of the Pym particles and it shrinks
and so when he calls it back to him it
comes back and it's this teensy little
hammer in the palm of his hand I and he
he's weirdly like embarrassed about it
at all hammer it's even smaller so yes
it is susceptible to Pym particle style
shrinking okay so that's the first part
of the answer but Thor is the only one
we see in the cartoon we'll do it still
so he's still worthy so it's not really
an issue so what about if a non worthy
human tries to grab it and I thought
it'd be more interesting if it was what
if they try to put him in mouth because
that's how I answer every question like
a baby it's like what if I chew on this
can I put it in my mouth
maybe one for my mouth fair but can I
put it in my mouth
it's important to remember that the
hammer is enchanted by magic it has
nothing to do with the infinite weight
of the hammer we actually covered that
and one of our very first episode it's a
big question how much does that yeah how
much does the hammer weigh first episode
anybody got to see cuz it wasn't too
crazy this you but yeah so we know that
the hammer essentially weighs forty two
point three pounds but that the magic is
what makes it unless the bolt so now we
have to go to a different episode a big
question that answered the question
about what happens if ant-man it becomes
giant man takes a big poop
but according to the ant-man movies the
way that the Pym particles affect these
objects is that they don't actually
change the object so much as they change
the distance between the atoms of the
object so it becomes kind of more or
less dense but it's say it should be the
same mass okay and that's really
important whether or not that's true
because if it's true this is insane
let's say me on the air gets shrunken
down to 1/100 of its size ok and then
you drop it into someone's hand or you
know try to toss in someone's mouth like
a potato chip if it's just 1/100 of its
size and ant-man is wrong about the way
that works it's only 0.4 to 3 pounds
right less than half a pound that's a
little less than 2 bananas 2 but it
might so little 2 bananas in your hand 2
bananas in your mouth it works trust me
put it in the middle and oh you're going
south you'd be ok in that scenario right
but if the ant-man films are correct
about the way Pym particles supposedly
worked then it's still 42 point 3 pounds
in mill near it's a giant mass and a
tiny little package which like story of
my life by the way huge mass teeny
package but can it go in the mouth
that's the ultimate big question so if
you take 40 2.3 pounds and put in this
teeny little package but you send it at
the same acceleration that just comes
with gravity so just drop it in
someone's hand or drop it into their
mouth that's 32 feet per second per
second so per second squared you can
calculate the force in specifically I'm
gonna I did it in foot-pounds and I'll
explain why in a second pounds don't
look at your foot so that number comes
out to be 673
one foot pounds of force when he dropped
this but why did I pick foot pounds I
don't know what that means because that
is how people measure the force of
bullets a 9-millimeter bullet weighs
only like a quarter of one ounce so 1/16
of one banana thank you for using a
banana for reference but that little
16th one banana bullet that's flying out
of that gun is coming out at 1,500 feet
per second so way faster than gravity
just falling right so that's why it does
so much damage hits with so much force
and again meal near forty two point
three pounds dropping into your hand or
into your mouth was 673 point one one
foot pounds of force this bullet fired
from a gun would hit you with 574
foot-pounds or Morse mill near just
dropping into your hand when it's tiny
would hit 20% harder than a
nine-millimeter bullet shot into your
hand or into your mouth it would blast
you open look at this look at us who
would thought not me just don't try to
feed a loved one tiny mule near is what
we're yeah all right it won't work I do
like that as I was researching this
there were like things where it's like
oh it might just knock you down real bad
or you'll have trouble lifting your hand
or your chin no it'll blast through that
[ __ ] like a bullet so once again we've
learned on big question that mule NER is
terrified ask questions about ya dad and
a Hulk thunderclap yeah all of it will
kill you everything will kill you we
would not survive a day in the Marvel
Universe not at all okay time for one
mailbag question this week what do we
got Philip do I got it
our official mail box with the question
is it a person or is it a place or is it
a thing round of question that will get
us fired
keep vamping what is your oldest memory
of feeling shame in the womb I can't
believe how I got made
worthy of living I got a story this is
the first time I can remember feeling
like this when I was 6 years old my
family rented a cabin in like this camp
out campgrounds area with a bunch of
other families that we knew and I was a
prince with one of the other kids in the
family well say his name was Freddy
we were screwing around I was 6 he was 5
both basically babies and we were
running around all day and then right
around dusk I snuck into his family's
cabin because I was gonna try to scare
him and I was looking around for him and
I walked to where his room was I look
over in the bathroom doors and put he
said another toilet get a [ __ ] and he
goes and I ran out of the cabin and I
hit her on the side of Cabot and I heard
his parents screaming out there like
Freddy what happened
he was like basically I was Angelica and
he was the Rugrats babies and he
couldn't explain what had happened and
he's like and they're like no you did it
like they didn't believe him and that so
his mom was like yeah right he's that
you think over there you're just being
an idiot and then so they stick their
head out the the cabin door and they go
Erik Erik and they yelled my name for 10
minutes I just hid in the bushes so
there was pretty [ __ ] and I was so
nervous I was like [ __ ] it's only
Saturday we have all day Sunday I'm
gonna see them they're gonna know I
didn't go to breakfast that we all
shared the next day I was like the
French coast is your favorite and I
didn't show up I didn't play with anyone
that day because I was so ashamed that
I'd seen his his bare thighs as these
takes [ __ ] this is manly very thighs
bare and then we had spaghetti for
dinner and I'm like I love spaghetti I
can't turn so I showed up and then no
one said anything to me you know you
know nervous the whole time
spaghetti and meatballs but his whole my
parents didn't believe him that believes
in ghosts now because of me
well don't think about their image of it
it's just like screaming from the
bathroom my dad run like what's
happening in here he's like on the
toilet like what could he have meant
probably maybe you see the toilet bowl
in there maybe it was like still potty
training and they thought he was just
making excuses to get off the toilet
they're like no you will sit on that
toilet until you [ __ ] mister you're not
gonna bring up Eric as an excuse for
this what if they that family never saw
you because you kept skipping the meals
too they thought Eric was like this
imaginary [ __ ] friends we all imagined
Eric is just what he names it's Terry
there's nothing in this boy Eric went
bye-bye
gross I love that my earliest shame is
at the exact same age as yours so it's
its first grade I'm 6 years old and
there's this girl in my class named
Lynette and Lynette was like it's not
that she was like heavy it was that she
had that thing that some girls get we're
like she's just growing so much faster
than everybody else so Lynette looked
like 10 but the rest of us were like 6
you like she might have been 10 I don't
know she was a 10 no so I was like 6 but
she like already was starting to like
become a woman or something and it was
like mind-boggling for me so like
they're just like stare her in class
sometimes like just like what is
happening to them and a six-year-old
because that's exactly that's what was
so so weird about it but like you know
no judgement to Lynette it was just
fascinating to my 8 my six-year-old eyes
and so I kind of like it's not that I
became obsessed with her but I would
just like think about her not a
gentleman's curiosity yes exactly I was
quite the gentle boy this is the story
of my first cut
kind of quasi erotic dream six years old
yeah I was 26 when you learned about
eroticism I was I ain't slept in a bunk
bed and I was on the top bunk and I it's
so weird that I still remember the dream
part of it Lynette is is there and she's
getting close to me and like nothing
it's not romantic in any way because I
don't understand any of that she just
keeps getting closer and closer to me
and she's so big that she starts to
envelop me and her skin is wrapping all
the way around me and then she kind of
starts to become maybe I'd seen on TV or
something like an anaconda or something
and so she starts wrapping my whole body
up in her skin and she's just so big and
she's like kind of crushing me but I
remember it didn't feel bad it kind of
like in my dream was like this feels
good I think and she she's just like
constricting me maybe to death but the
reason I didn't feel so bad about that I
didn't understand what's happening in
the dream but when I woke up and in the
middle of the night and I came to I
looked down and I had shredded my pajama
pants in two pieces just like Oh tore
him to shreds like who knows when I was
I was buying him so much that I just
like like there was ribbons Jama pants
you Hawk down your pajamas because of
your unberthing dream yeah I was six
years old and I I felt so much guilt
because I knew I'd done something really
dirty and I did it so bad that I've
ruined my pants I bawled him up and I
threw them down the side of the bed
which only meant they felt no one can
find them exactly but I definitely knew
what I done was so wrong and I think I
like I even couldn't even talk to
Lynette how could that anymore now
without immediately ripping my pants off
we used to be friends Phillip come on
[Applause]
I'm still so embarrassed about I didn't
even know what I was doing down there
just cops
there's a woman v to that right like she
just screw largest most maternal to you
and exactly that's so wrong gives us a
girl we're talking about yeah and then I
stab my eyes out yes I have to take
these out and like wash my ears forever
after hearing that I was so little I
didn't know I did much worse stuff later
age doesn't forgive knowledge of the law
I'm so lucky I don't go to jail the it
legal dreams every episode Philippines
in a bit of regret I just learning the
thing is I've lived with all this stuff
my whole life I know these Thanks every
single day plane so much exactly it just
better explains to other people why I'm
kind of like unshakable I think like
it's like it's right whatever I've seen
it when I was six
nothing nothing rattles pillow nothing
shakes you like yeah I've already had
that horrible thought move on that's the
same age I was when I told that story
about my mom's friend who said she was
gonna shift this she'll you've lived
four lifetimes
by the time house six it was very
formative that's our show I always feel
like just sailing or normal script is
always like recovering from I think it's
so funny it's kind of like Rachael Ray's
cooking show and that's how it starts
with the recipes I'm like well let's see
how the turkey turned out and then like
later it's like I killed a man in the
Vegas and I got away with it
and everyday laundry my dreams well
let's do view have fun recipes there's
something fun to share with you every
time we tape one of these episodes I go
downstairs and I talk to my girlfriend
and she is so what were you guys talking
to it she has so many questions cuz
she's only heard my half of it it's just
like wait so what what did you do
yes she only hears your side and thinks
the word she's like you stole that
girl's blazer I can't believe you so
give her back her blazer but on the
other side feels like I started the
Chicago fire questions are always I need
ages and current contact information I
just need to know because like then we
need we need to get married faster so
that I can't testify against you it has
to be a speed wedding
okay well reminder that you can join our
official discord right becoming a patron
at patreon.com yeah that's new rock
stars you could get audio versions of
the show another by subscribing to new
rock stars big question wherever you get
your podcasts and thanks to everyone who
submitted questions in our comment
sections using the hashtag big question
on Twitter or by hitting us upon discord
this Court's probably gonna be the way
we're gonna see it first so really gonna
need to become a patron join us on
discord if you really want to get our
attention fastest you can also mail us
at our p o-- box we love getting mail
from you guys it's always the best you
know what else we love getting from you
guys
fan art look somebody did this fan art
of us recently i think it's hilarious
and i love it
it's amazing i love six things about
this so my comments try to figure out
what my six favorite things are about
that but yeah send us more fan art and
we'll feature on the show we love it it
makes us feel good about our life
choices follow me on social media EA vos
follow Phillip at Phillip Molina and you
can follow the new rock stars on all
social media and subscribe here on
YouTube to get too much information
about all that stuff you care about see
you next week bye bye
[Music]